hello everyone and welcome to the last
game we'll be showing from the opera
euro rapids tournament it's maxine
bashar al-agrav versus tamar rajabov
this is the
second game of the second match but
before we check this out i would just
like to mention that
the fide candidates tournament is to be
resumed
in april this year and as it states on
the
official feed page fide has today
announced that the candidates tournament
in yakatori
russia will resume on the eighth round
taking place on april 19th
so 389 days after the event was stopped
midway
uh the chess world should finally get to
know who magnus carlsen will face in his
fifth world championship match scheduled
for dubai
uh in november so there we have it and i
thought it was a very
uh fitting that here we have uh mathema
sherlock who is currently leading the
candidates tournament and taymur rajabov
who
dropped out of the candidate candace
tournament and uh
due to his dropping out maxim got uh got
in
so very interesting that the two of them
are fighting it out for
for third place and this opera euro
rapid and this game features a move that
is um
that simply cannot be explained so best
for me to just show it to you and then
we can take it from there
so this is the second game uh uh tamer
won the first game where he had the
white pieces so maxime opens with e4
and much like maxine timur also goes for
the sicilian defense we have c5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and now d4
striking in the center we have captures
captures and now
e5 this is the early uh advancement of
the eep on the so-called low intel
variation
uh some of the different than what
you're used to seeing in the knight of
six knight c3 and the e5 the so-called
alaska or the pelican or the swedenkov
that we've seen in the world
championship match between for example
fabi and the magnus
so here we have the early e5 knight to
b5 now going after the d6 square and now
d6 by black we have c4 grabbing more
space in the center
and tamer continues development just
bishop to e7
we have knight to c3 and now a6 pushing
this knight back
knife to a3 the knight is now coming to
c2 and then to e3 and from e3 will have
access to d5 and f5 squares
so f5 right away we have e captures and
the bishop captures on f5
now knight to c2 going after e3 as the
bishop is now on f5
knight to f6 and knight to e3 we have
bishop back to e6 and the g3 now
preparing to fianchetto the light square
bishop
uh we have castles and now bishop to g2
we have queen to d7
now with this queen bishop battle we
want to play bishop to h3
and the grab hold of white's light
square bishop and then it's going to be
a little bit easier to attack white
so here uh the usual move is just
castles there are nine games in the
database where this move has been played
but
in this game knight c to d5 is played by
maxine
and it is as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game
uh so here uh rook 8 e8 now you cannot
continue with bishop to h3 because
knight b6
and well your queen and rook would be
under attack so here first
rook goes to e8 and only now we have
castles
and bishop to d8 now not allowing this
knights to be traded for bishop and the
bishop nicely controls all of these
squares so you don't have to worry about
any jumps
also very useful or useful to know when
the bishop and knight are apart two
squares
then the bishop nicely controls the
knight and vice versa
so here b3 preparing to finka to the
light square bishop as well
and only now bishop to h3 uh threatening
to
trade off white's very strong defender
here
bishop to b2 and now bishop captures on
g2 we have king capture sanji
ii and now knight to e7 uh trying to
trade off this knight
uh uh well the knights we have knight
captures on f6 rook
captures and now rook to c1
uh so here after rook to c1 we have
queen to c6 with
check remaneuvering the queen knight to
d5 now blocking and here
bishop to b6 uh now the idea is um tamer
wants to shift this bishop to d4 to
trade it for
uh white's dark square bishop so here
f4 striking in the center and now bishop
to d4
we have captures on d4 now in in between
move
knight captures and the five threatening
is a very nasty discovery so you have to
capture the knight
queen captures with check and now you're
gonna win back your
uh your bishop so here queen f3 offering
a queen trade
and now uh rajavo just trades queen
captures on f3
uh he was uh he was not interested in
queen captures on d4 leaving the queens
on the board
i imagine because he already won the
first game and he won the
first match in its entirety so i i guess
he's uh he just wants to keep it simple
but queen captures was very interesting
because after queen captures on b7
queen d2 check now you cannot block with
the rook because this rook is hanging
so king to g1 and now rook to h6
threatening checkmate and
once the queen stops checkmate now you
go queen either reach a king h1
and now you capture on f4 so this is the
position
uh uh he could have gotten but i guess
he decided that it's not uh
it's not worth it uh risking it because
black would also
uh be a little bit vulnerable uh so he
decides to just trade queens and
in the next game he's going to have the
white pieces anyway so why why
uh why rush into something so queen
captures uh we have king captures on f3
and now uh winning back the bishop e
captures on d4
we have rook f2d1 now going after this
pawn and
rook the e3 check we have king to f2 and
now
rook f2 e6 going for this check and then
you're gonna go after the
second ranked pawn so here rook captures
on d4
uh saying not a problem we have rookie
to check king of three and
captures on h2 ready to capture on a2
next
uh we have a4 not allowing this capture
and
now h5 h5 is a great move uh you might
also think but why not for example
rook here and after white captures this
then h5
worth threatening checkmate looks very
nice problem is after rook to f1
you don't have checkmate and you've
basically just given up this pawn
so here uh tamor says i'm just gonna
hang on to this pawn and play h5 first
so maybe if you don't react to anything
maybe then i'm gonna try something like
that
but maksim immediately makes room for
his king with f5
attacking the rook here rook to e5 and
now even
g4 so here h captures on g4
king g3 attacking the rook and rook to
b2 now
with rook captures on d6 and rook
captures on f5 we have king captures on
g4
attacking the rook and rook b back to f
sorry rook b back to f2 all right uh
it might sound uh like a good idea to
you know keep this rook here to attack
this one but it could also be very
very dangerous for example uh if you go
somewhere like uh
rook rook to f7 and then let's say
what uh white could do let's say rook to
b6 then the pawn is defended
uh and you haven't really you haven't
really accomplished much
uh but uh you know it's hard to say
what what's better here because it's uh
uh these rook end games are always
so so drawisher but only there are maybe
some
very very few few positions that are
like uh you know
super super crazy winning position so
it's it's hard to say
so here rook beat the f2 now just uh
doubling up here maybe try
uh at least you're very safe here you
can always keep harassing the the white
king if nothing else but you're still up
a pawn so
tamer definitely will try something here
so here rook the c
not that rook the c8 with check king to
h7
and now rook to c4 uh not allowing any
checks to come uh this way
we have b5 offering a trade a captures
and
now rook captures with an attack on this
pawn but just
king to g3 attacking the rook here rook
to f6
offering a trade and white trades
captures captures and now as this pawn
is under attack
just b4 so the pawn is defended with a5
tamer uh trades off at this point as
well we have captures captures
and now rook to h4 with check and now
it's a king rook and pawn against king
and rook and this is of course a
completely drawn end game
it's uh you know uh a table based draw
basically there's no way
uh you can play for a win here and both
of them know this but
what happens next is it pretty much uh
pretty insane
here we have king to g6 rook to g4 check
and now we have rook the g5 just
blocking check and now
uh feel free to pause the video here and
try to find a move that
does not lose the game for white so
while i give you a couple of seconds
have at it
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
not playing something like king f2 king
g2
king h2 but also uh congratulations if
you decided
not to capture the rook capturing the
rook actually loses the game so what you
have to play
here is something like this king of four
king of three king h4 king h3
so these moves are okay but capturing on
g5 is absolutely not okay
and uh remarkable as it is this is
exactly what maxine played he allowed
tamer to grab this opposition and now uh
it's basically it's it's the most basic
of all end games uh
you gain the opposition you are able to
win uh squares
in in front of your opponent's king and
you will be able to win this end game so
now
king to f3 team will just play king to
f5 we have and now
you have to play something and it
doesn't matter what you play if you go
here then the black king goes here if
you go here the black king goes here
so maxine played king f2 but now just
king to f4
and it is well known that if you have if
you have control of these squares in
front of your pawn with the king then
the game is just
winning as now white has to move you
again gain the opposition
so for those of you who are new to chess
i will show it as it's very interesting
so once the king moves you're just going
to move your king closer
you have to reach this square so you
control all of these squares and then
you just want to march your pawn all the
way through these squares so here
king f1 king the f3 now again
you have the opposition the white king
has to move king e1 and now you start
pushing your pawn king f1 you push the
pawn again
you have the opposition king you want
not just king g2
and you have control of these three
squares and now it's just winning king
g2
check doesn't matter what you play check
check check check
and now you will checkmate the the white
king easily
so of course the maxim knows this and
after king to f4 he resigned
the game but this is a very special
moment for chess in general uh
you know remember this position very
well
and you know show it to everyone to your
friends at the bar in the library
because
it's amazing that maksim who is
currently leading the fita candidates
tournament and
might you know definitely has good
chances of challenging magnus carlsen
for the title of world champion played
rook captures on g5 in this position and
allowed this completely winning end game
and the these are
the absolute uh you know the the most
basic of basics
so i have no idea how such a thing could
happen maybe
maybe maxine uh stopped caring
altogether about this tournament maybe
he's just you know
uh interested in continuing the
candidates tournament and maybe
that's the only thing that occupies his
mind currently but it is uh always uh
interesting and this is something that i
always mention you know blunders are for
everyone no one is immune
and whenever you blunder something or
you have you know you you play a
brilliant game and then you ruin it
don't worry it happens to everyone and
you know it's
the you are not the problem uh so here
if it can happen to maxime then i mean
uh it definitely can happen to everyone
i knew i know when i was still playing
uh over the board chess like 10 years
ago i was playing some tournament
and i played a really good game and then
i made such a mistake a mistake such as
this one and i was like
wha what is wrong with me you know
should i just stop existing i mean
yeah it makes no sense uh but yeah it
happens to everyone so
you know bear that in mind next time you
blunder and and you will blunder you
know
that's uh that's uh that that's uh you
know the only absolute in the universe
uh but yeah uh like i said uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it the last
game we'll be showing from the opera
euro rapid we are continuing with what
we usually do you know the morphe saga
and so on
uh i would like to thank mr hoody guy
chuchao john aleva bobby aleva
uh obviously john's dog and it's
actually a contribution for meadow so
there you have it meadow you have
received a contribution and
a monero supporter for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day
and also uh sorry about that i forgot to
mention yeah
these are the the standings uh of the
candidates tournament uh
in case you forgot so maxime and niepo
are uh leading the tournament followed
by fabiano grishok
uh van gaal and anishigiri and then in
last place with two and a half points uh
kiralaksenko and
ding liran who is having the the
probably the worst tournament of his
life and
what you know the absolute worst time to
have such a tournament is
is the candidates tournament uh but yeah
uh i hope you guys enjoyed it uh see you
soon